bueno en el resto de europa como en los
estados de derecho no es que vivimos
funcionamos con la libertad de expresión
siempre obviamente que no ofendas que no
insultes que no de infames que no
diatribas que no destruyas al otro lo
que pasa que los límites que tienen
estas colectividades muslim las
musulmanas radicales pues es muy pequeño
pero vamos yo puedo perfectamente decir
que no creo en una nube o entrar credo o
que las doctrinas de la iglesia
cristiana católica protestante ortodoxa
me aparecen tal y entraría dentro de mi
libertad de expresión y nadie me va a
decir nada pero claro cuando el
colectivo que recepciona esto en este
caso los musulmanes radicales entienden
que esto va a contra sus principios
básicos o su ortodoxia más oscura pues
entonces destruyen la libertad de
expresión la libertad de expresión en la
unión europea está muy bien regulada
entienda usted que es el lugar del mundo
donde las libertades civiles y
colectivas están más garantizadas y más
en españa que es el estado más
garantista no por encima incluso de eeuu
estoy sorprendido coincido plenamente
con el proceso anterior de que una
cierta expresión absolutamente pequeña
normal genere esto y sobre todo genere
de muerte la muerte y destrucción ahora
usted como historiador como ve lo que
está ocurriendo ahora con estos
extremistas islámicos se repite un poco
la historia que vimos siglos atrás con
otras religiones
no para pensar yo como historiador
profesional digo afirmó en manifiesto
rotundamente que la historia nunca con
mayúsculas se repiten y luego echar
echar o intentar analizar hechos de hoy-
con lo que ha pasado en épocas
pretéritas es muy peligroso estoy muy
perdidos las situaciones causas de
vector son muy peligrosas lo que está
sucediendo es que van a mínimos en un
mundo del cual hay una minoría de
rotunda radical y absoluta radicalidad y
dictadura intelectual frente una mayoría
pues que acepta la convivencia no esto
tiene yo creo que un poco que ver con
los dos y giras del pasado bueno porque
para empezar a ver si se cree usted sí
que me está oyendo que los musulmanes
cuando conquistaron de arabia saudita el
reto del mundo regalaban flores no en
españa
tuvieron el califato y al andaluz pues
pues ya no luego entraron a sangre y
fuego y destruyeron a todos los
cristianos a todos los visigodos
que estaban en su contra sé que también
podríamos estar muchas horas no tengo
tiempo no es que tampoco me va a
permitir por premura de tiempo porque
ten mucho cuidado con esto es decir la
situación es la que es
'estamos europa tiene millones de
inmigrantes qué tal con una tolerancia
absoluta absoluta como digo como ningún
lugar en el mundo esto afirmó con
solemnidad entonces el programa de ellos
de los que matan no no de la historia ni
de los que les permitimos la convivencia
en paz en quietud y en asia y en dios y
nunca mejor dicho señora es buena
también queremos preguntarle el
presidente macro no ha mantenido una
postura muy fuerte muy firme respecto a
las libertades ciudadanas usted
considera que una postura menos fuerte
evitaría este tipo de ataques o estaría
mostrando debilidad de parte del
mandatario
no considero que hay que aplicar la ley
no la ley la ley de occidente la ley de
la unión europea no la ley que nunca va
a ser la ley de ellos no que el otro día
decapiten a un pobre profesor y que hoy
ejecuten de manera como si fueran
animales a tres personas pues ya dice
dice los parámetros de su ley
sanguinaria no no no no de debilidad
nada yo creo que los estados de la unión
son muy poderosos en sí mismos en cuanto
a sus cuerpos legislativos y por
supuesto además tienen una legislación
global yo creo que hay que aplicar la
ley de manera efectiva y de manera
efectiva es decir ni más ni menos los
cometido unos delitos dos cometido nada
menos que asesinato y tienes que pagarlo
yo creo que macrón está haciendo lo que
cualquier estadista está haciendo lo que
hacen los gobiernos españoles por
ejemplo independientemente de quién de
qué partido ante el fenómeno terrorista
que hemos tenido hasta el año 2011 con
el caso de eta y ahora también tenemos
con el caso de mucho mal yo creo que se
está haciendo lo correcto
y que utilizar todos los resortes de la
ley para terminar con este con esta
lacra mundial
con la que no vamos a terminar ellos se
lo explico a mis alumnos les vamos a
seguir teniendo terrorismo muchos link
durante muchos muchos muchos años porque
forma parte del concepto de la
irracionalidad más preca más preclara y
sobre todo la venganza porque una
revista hecho ha hecho unas a una sátira
con el presidente de tu río'
genere estas reacciones pues solamente
insiste una vez más permite también el
malestar del terrorista que somete el
mal no no los demás